guys we live in a time where
millionaires and billionaires love to
manipulate the market like they're
brushing their teeth they just do it
because they can they see another one do
it and they go hey it's like golfing
like someone hits the ball far and the
guy goes i can manipulate the market
even more than you can that's what
happened with the dave portnoy copying
elon musk the man got a little jealous
of big bro elon musk and decided if he
can manipulate the market
like we showed in the last video of
bitcoin and doge i can manipulate the
market too and i'm here to tell you
don't fall for it please
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla ah
you think i'd figure out how to say that
i've said it so many times uh the reason
i'm talking to you i'm on a mission of
mercy
i'm here from mitch and murray and i'm
here on a mission of mercy
hey look you're gonna see this around
and it's funny dave portnoy
is manipulating the market and he's
doing it and he's just saying like evan
dude we kind of live in a crazy la la
land time let's just have a la la land
fun time
and honestly you're gonna watch this
you're gonna go for a second
you're going to want to gamble but then
you have to remember what am i doing
am i just making a millionaire rich
again why do you guys do this
please for the love of god crypto
deserves better than dave portnoy
just creating random picking random
coins
that are probably ponzi's games and
chilling them so if you don't know what
i'm talking about
uh this was released yesterday dave
portnoy
founder of barstool sports if you guys
don't know throwing his hat in the ring
because he was sick of elon musk
manipulating all the coins press
conference um
as people know i am the baron of bitcoin
i will never sell my bitcoin i will
never waver in bitcoin
yo anyone who says they have diamond
hands they always have paper hands by
the way they're always the first to sell
that's necessary here with elon musk
says i'm sticking with bitcoin
but the event of the last couple days
and weeks have made me think
i have to get involved in something
beyond bitcoin i see what elon does he's
pulling levers
so one day doge is good next is bad
bitcoin good
bitcoin bad it's time for me to choose a
side
and i've done that so he basically goes
hey yeah elon musk is manipulating the
market
i can't do it because i don't have a big
enough social media following so i'll
find my own market to manipulate that's
what this guy is about to do
and here we go doge ass litecoin
safe move shiva hoge
the new breed of [ __ ] coins and i'm
gonna pick one and i'm gonna become the
leader
okay this is objectively funny it's like
the funniest scam i've covered so it's
like hot
it's hard because i know a lot of you
are again i know you i know my audience
i know a lot of my audience is like
it's a scam but is it fun though can i
have a fun time while losing money
stop it i'm i'm here to tell you stop
stop what you're doing
check it look have a gamble account make
it like less than a percent of your net
worth but do not
put money where you can't lose it guys
please forty
thousand dollars of the coin that i will
declare my allegiance to
i told everybody at parsons hey this is
my coin
i will not sell in the near future i
will stick with it
i will do it i will ride it either to
the stratosphere
or hell on earth so here we go dave
portnoy
founder of barcelo sports found all
right get to the point here so he puts
on the caps
and of course he picks drum roll please
the answer is safe mode
safe moon is not yeah you know that
trash coin we reviewed like
a month ago yeah that one now in
the dave portnoy business and vice versa
why i don't know why it could be a ponzi
scheme
i like the word moon because that's
where i want to go
dude at least he's honest look is it
market manipulation
yes is it a trash way to scam your
followers
yes also yes is the sec gonna do
anything about it
no no because you know what the sec is
doing right now they're having a
beautiful
nap time i don't know what the sec is
doing they're doing jack
dude they're doing nothing elon musk
when it plays the market
dave portnoy manipulates the market
anybody else
touches their twitter account talks
about any stock
bank i don't know it's incredible to me
that in the crypto space so many people
are getting away with this
but i think this is what's going to get
the market regulated when the sec sees
stuff like this
is they're going to be like oh yeah you
can't do that if i
ever had to give somebody a good
argument for why we're in a bubble with
crypto this would be it the fact that
this video
not only was seen but was seen 1.6
million times and
the price of safe moon i think went up
25
even though he's not a financial advisor
and telling you he's not a financial
advisor surprise surprise
people end up investing in the thing
he's shilling this is the best argument
for why we're in a bubble i mean
literally the guy saying
is it a ponzi scheme i like it it says
moon in it
moon it's like dude i mean like i know
the guy's rich and losing 40k doesn't
matter
him but it is kind of a little scummy
like you're like shilling it to all your
followers
who probably a lot of them are like blue
collar guys
it's like it means nothing if you lose
it if they lose it
it actually matters it's pretty scummy
to me everyone ponzi ponzi ponzi
it's early if it is a ponzi get in on
the ground floor
to the moon okay dude again
objectively funny if anyone tells me
this isn't funny
you're lying to yourself it's like if
bernie madoff had a sense of humor
honestly he'd be like hey is it a ponzi
i don't know
like get in early i mean you're early so
why not why not sure it's a potsy
whatever
what it's a ponzi like get in early dad
the moon
safely we go make my eyes blue
make them blue that's the new thing i
already have blue eyes i want lasers
safe moon get in now maybe
moon safe there it is i don't know what
you're doing invest responsibly
oh there it is there it finally is i
don't know what i'm doing i'm not i was
financial advisor this is the bet look
if you're smart and you see this
[Music]
hey you realize we're in a bubble right
you get real comfortable with the fact
that we're deep in a bubble right now
when this goes viral and it gets
millions of hits
uh and people actually make decisions
based on a dave portnoy tweet
we're viral when the value of a crypto
token is literally just
did a guy with a twitter account make a
video about it
saying that yeah who cares if it's a
ponzi and then it goes up
we're in a bubble oh and by the way uh
right before he did this he tweeted that
his whole intention of uh announcing his
coin that he already bought
was just to move the markets so he
literally is like yeah i bought this
and i'm basically going to talk about it
so that i can manipulate the markets
i mean look is this that different from
what wall street does a lot of the time
no not what they're actually a lot of
times they're just manipulating the
market but the difference is is that
he's promoting something that's
actually has no value it actually does
has no purpose
in the world it's mind-blowing to me and
honestly it's gonna be sad when all
these people's coins go to zero
but uh you know what look in the
meantime enjoy it enjoy
the memes enjoy watching this dumpster
fire and you know what just be safe guys
be safe because i know i know my
audience and i know some of you guys are
looking at this going
that looks real tempting i wanna
want to gamble i want to go to vegas
with dave no you don't
because when dave loses 40k he goes to
another table
when you lose 40k you lose your car
all right that's basically it i hope you
guys are
smart don't fall for these stupid
celebrities just manipulating the market
because
yolo they can and elon musk did it i
find it annoying
this one was pretty funny but still is
annoying
so thanks for watching i hope you
enjoyed please invest responsibly
don't be an idiot i'll see you guys next
time